[Music]
i have in my notes here crime and
punishment by dostoyevsky as a book that
was important to you
and
i would like to know why that is the
case
so that book is actually what got me
into philosophy originally
back when i was about 15 i read it and i
was at a time
variance in literature i wanted to be a
poet and an author
and
it was via that that i learned about
this word philosophy and i realized that
like oh actually you can just tackle the
big ideas directly you don't need to go
via fiction
but i was also particularly in the time
in existentialist
philosophy
and
this is something that honestly like i
kind of still bear with me i'm kind of a
bit unusual in that
i often think to myself
could i justify my life now to my 15
year old self
and if the answer is no then i'm a bit
like oh what are you doing you're not
living up to
what earlier will would have wanted for
pleasant will
and the key thing i think for 15 year
old will who was inspired by
existentialism was living an authentic
life
and
i still find that
very
liberating and empowering and inspiring
so some of the things i do so for
example i've i give away most of my
income which is like a very unusual
thing to do and you might think
oh that's like a sacrifice that's making
my life worse but actually i find it
kind of empowering because it's like
i am making an autonomous decision i am
like not merely kind of following the
dictates of
what social convention is telling me to
do but i'm like reasoning about things
from first principles and then making a
decision that's like genuinely
authentically mine
and that was something
i hadn't particularly
pegged it to kind of acting morally when
i was 15 although to some extent but
that was something that really moved me
then
and
yeah honestly continues to move me today
so how would you just
for i i often say for the listeners out
there who may not be familiar but
honestly if i'm being honest with myself
i i have not studied existentialism and
i i hear certain names associated with
it so i can kind of fake it until i make
it and give it create the illusion i'll
be like ah you know kirkegaard i think
maybe uh this person that person but
what is existentialism as it is
portrayed in crime and punishment
or conveyed
well i think one of the things i liked
about climate punishment and
dostoevsky's work in particular
is that it kind of
it at least is wrestling with
existentialism
so
and that can work can get used in
various ways
but here
one way of thinking about it is just
the world as it is like has no intrinsic
meaning
yeah and yet we are like placed into it
and have to make decisions
and that's this like absurd position to
be in
and
you can
create your own meaning out of that
through
like
radically free acts
like authentic genuine acts
and
dostoyevsky in his work kind of wrestles
between
like three positions i think
one is this like existentialist position
a second is just pure nihilism which is
just like actually literally if you take
it seriously like and there's no god
then everything is permitted there's no
reason to do anything not even like
reason creators aren't
you know from yourself
and then third is this religious
position which i think he actually
ultimately endorses
and it's almost like
nihilism as
like a proof
like the rejection of nihilism like
therefore guarantees that you should be
like religious qed god yeah
exactly yeah well it's like
life is meaningless unless um god exists
and i'm now describing it slightly
pascali in terms but like you may as
well act as if there's a god that is
giving meaning to life
you